yo what is up everybody it is
prestigious mad luigi here with another
borderlands z3 sequel video now actually
this really isn't going to be a video
too much about borland's pre-sequel
there is some gamepl
and priyan whatever you call it sentinel
but that's just some back game place
that i can say what i want to say and
also if my voice a little bit nasally
and a little bit less enthusiastic than
normal i apologize because i do have
pretty bad cold and that's gonna be
causing that so um let's get into what i
want to talk about
really this video i want to use this
time to say thank you to
everyone that has supported my channel
everyone that has subscribed or viewed
my videos or like my videos
since um i since i started posting
borderlines of pre-sequel a lot has
happened
uh before uh before the pre-sequel i
posted minecraft called duty on my
channel kind of generic stuff not too
interesting and i did that for about two
years
i maybe like a year
a year and a few months since i took
some huge hiatuses and breaks in between
there and i was i came back from a
pretty big hiatus
um
before the pre-sequel
coming back and posting pre-sequel was
the return of that break
and i got the
nell uh guide up and that got 170 000
views and since i started posting the
pre-sequel content my subscriber count
has almost doubled right now it's at
1356
it was at around 700 before i started
posting this about a little over a month
ago
and i
am i'm just really i'm really
appreciative since i know that even
even though that this isn't a large
amount at all this is like one 100th
1000th of what a ton of other youtubers
have it does mean a lot to me and i do
appreciate all of the support i've been
given through it
so i just i i want to take this time
thank you guys anyone has watched or
clicked or subscribed
and i hope that in the future you will
continue to love and sub and uh support
my videos i also happy thanksgiving you
might see this a little late because it
is late on thanksgiving when i'm
recording this and yeah hope you guys
have a good day peace out